breaking it for the arrest report
detailing the conditions of the two
women involved in that brutal crash that
killed two toddlers thank you for
joining us at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and
I'm Christian Casitas will that crash
happening on November 11th Madison
Kimbrough is live in our Newsroom with
the details Madison good afternoon yeah
that was actually December 11th then
Kalia Manning the toddler's aunt is
accused of driving drunk while behind
the wheel the children's Mother Ranisha
Washington was riding in the passenger
seat the two girls Taylor and Rosemarie
Wilmer both just two and three years old
when they passed away in the newly
released police report North Las Vegas
Police Department noting that this was a
chaotic scene with debris and pieces of
vehicle thrown all over the travel lanes
that was on Scott Robertson Boulevard
near Lone Mountain and Clayton now in
the report it states that two-year-old
rose body was found outside of the
vehicle police also stating that the
driver Clea Manning was conscious and
shaking the children's Mother renisha
Washington who was unconscious in the
passenger seat Manning suffered a
ruptured spleen and internal bleeding
Washington a ruptured bladder spinal and
hip injury and she broke her femur
police reported a strong odor of alcohol
could be smelled from the driver's area
of the car and Manning's eyes were
bloodshot now when asked how much
alcohol she consumed she started crying
and told the officer that she had two
shots and that she thought she was fine
the women did say they did not have
child car seats the mother of the girls
told police she just sold them reporting
in The Newsroom Madison Kimberly news
now Manning is facing several charges
including a DUI child restraint
violation as well as failure to maintain
lanes while the children's Mother is
facing child abuse and neglect charges
they are both expected to appear in
court tomorrow morning Christian